i'd to thank everybody this evening
for joining us on our journey through
a bed which literally translates to
the provisions taken
and prepared for the great appointment
meaning the day of resurrection these
provisions are taken
from the ways and traditions
and sunan of the best of mankind
[Arabic recitation]
so what is the nature of this book this
book was authored by
islam sudden even
who is more formally known as ibn
al-qaeda
one of the great students of ibn
taymiyyah
and he is one of the major teachers of
ibn kathir the
mufester what is this book about
well ibn al-qayyim when he gave this
name to this book
he puts a particular image in our minds
and that is that look all of us are on a
journey to allah
every one of us is on that journey
whether he likes it or not whether he
tries to remain
stagnant in his life or he
goes forward and advances or even if he
tries to retreat
if you are a human being you are on a
journey
a perpetual journey to allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
and so this journey a person needs to
take provisions
meaning a person needs to prepare
himself for this journey
and the ultimate journey is when we
transition
from this life into the hereafter
that is the ultimate journey and so
just any journey any vacation any
trip that we take
we have to prepare ourselves we have to
have
you know in more modern times we usually
carry
checks or cards but we also need food
and we need to make sure our vehicle
is up to par and so on and so forth this
is
called taking provisions and allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala said about taking
provisions
and preparing oneself for the journey
he said take provisions for your journey
and the best of provisions is the
provision
of piety of dutifulness
of righteousness that is the best
provision that you can take for yourself
on your journey to allah subhanahu wa
and so what is the topic of this book
the topic of this book is the entire
sunnah of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam everything that is
relevant to know about him
goes into how the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam spoke how he slept
the positions he sat in how he would
speak how he would stand how he would
walk
who were his closest companions who were
his wives
what is his biography
how did he used to
administer medicine right so the whole
fourth volume
of is regarding the
medicine of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
how he would judge between people how he
would make salah
how he would make hajj how he would fast
etc etc
this book is a remarkable book
because it almost encompassed
every single aspect
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's life
before islam and after islam
that is quite a feat and that can only
be done by a scholar who has
absolutely become an ocean a fountain of
knowledge and that is
what is even more startling about this
book
is that ibn kayum wrote this book in
five volumes
and he wrote it entirely from memory
because he was on his way to hajj when
he wrote it
and he re referenced in this book zadil
more than 200 other books verbatim
meaning word for word from memory
and it became one of the the most
influential books in the history of
islam
and it remains one of the most integral
references in the islamic library
i cannot emphasize enough the importance
of this book zadil ma'at right
so where we were in this book is we were
speaking about
how the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would visit the ill
how he would visit the sick and
ibn then goes on
and kind of bleeds that into the issue
of
preparation for death and how
he would go about preparing a person for
death
while he is on his deathbed all the way
until he is placed in his grave
so we are going to go through now the
way that he would pray salah till geneza
we would go through how he would
make the grave and prepare the grave we
are going to be discussing
how the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
prepared the body for burial and
what he would do immediately as a person
was fading away into the hereafter
and what he would do after the person
had passed away
all the way until visiting the graves
because it doesn't end with a person's
death right
it doesn't end with a person just being
put in his grave
it doesn't end there we still have
responsibilities to our
towards our brothers just because our
brother is passed away
doesn't mean he's forgotten no brother
is left
forgotten no one not even
someone that is us obscure
and i'll give you an example of this
from the sunnah
in sahih al-bukhari it's narrated that
one woman that used to
sweep and clean the masjid she that's
what all she did
as a matter of fact her name is not
exactly known
this is how obscure she was amongst the
companions
she would come in at night or in the
morning before everybody was there
and clean the masjid up whatever people
had left
of course the masjid of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
its doors were always open there were
only doors
but there were no no actual doors that
would lock
and so it was open perpetually day and
night
so animals used to go in there dogs
would go inside
snakes would go inside and she would go
in there and clean up after these
animals and after the people as well
and so she fell ill and passed away
and the companions whoever knew her a
small
following prepared her body
gave her her last islamic rights and
buried her
well after a while the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam noticed
that he didn't see her anymore
so he asked about her what happened to
her
and he was told she passed away
and we buried her and the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam became
a little bit annoyed by this and he said
why didn't you tell me about this
of course they thought you know this is
the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam he's busy with the
armies and he's busy with the companions
and teaching and being a husband and
being a father and being
a prophet and being so he is
you know he's busy and so they didn't
want to disturb him with such an obscure
death
right not every single death he would
attend the funeral so
he said why didn't you
tell me that then he said
take me to her grave
and so the companions
led the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
to the place where she had been buried
to her grave
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
prayed over the grave
right and this was the first
and last time he ever prayed solatil
geneza
over a grave never before had he done
that
and never never after had he done it
right and then he turned to the
companions and he said
the graves of these individuals
meaning the people buried in this
cemetery
are muslim they are shrouded
in darkness and my prayer upon them
enlightens that grave and illuminates it
upon its people and so he showed
great importance to this
woman who was obscure in the
grand scheme of things but not obscure
to allah
and not obscure to the messenger of
allah
sallallahu alaihi
now
it doesn't end there even even after
we've prayed
even after we bury a person
there's still visitation of the grave
the prophet salallahu
would often visit the graves of al-baqir
right which is the graveyard on the
outskirts of medina which the majority
of the companions are buried in
likewise he would go out to
where the martyrs of that battle were
buried
and he would pray solatill janaza there
and he would also visit those
those graves and so
it doesn't end with that also the
family members of the deceased the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
keep in contact with them
even the friends of the deceased
he would keep in contact with them
khadijah
his wife his late wife
radhiallahuanha his first
and the one whom most of his children
are from
way after her death all the way in
medina
whenever he would slaughter an animal
he would designate a portion of that
animal
to be sent to khadija's friends
right why because this is part of his
dutifulness
and likewise a person whose father
passes away
or whose mother passes away
it is not just enough to visit her grave
or his
but also to continue
to maintain contact with
the deceased's close
friends and relatives this is all part
of
so it never ends we're always connected
believers the believers do not cease
their connection with death
death is not the end of their connection
death is not the end of their
dutifulness to
to one another this is an important
concept that we have to understand
and we have to take to heart so this
chapter
that we are currently speaking of
and delving into this chapter
is regarding these concepts and so we
will read along with what ibm
rahimahullah and we will start to
understand
portions of the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
with regards to these issues
he says the first thing is that when a
person would fall
ill a muslim would fall ill
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would consistently
visit the person we mention
visiting someone who is ill
this visitation its
appropriate time and place
depends on the time and place
so in our current culture it's probably
not
it's probably not
appropriate to visit someone at three
o'clock in the morning in his home
right it's appropriate to
visit during daylight hours or early
evening
for instance likewise
it may be appropriate to sp spend a long
time
if you go to visit someone who's ill and
you see that they
desire that you spend a lot of time
then what's appropriate is for you to
and to stay there with them for
as long as is appropriate
sometimes it's only appropriate to visit
for a few minutes
right depending on the situation
depending on what
kind of familial situation
this person is having when a person goes
to visit
the ill they should remind the person
of the hereafter
they should remind the person
that if they have not completed their
will to complete their will
also they should remind the person to
repent
sincerely and earnestly to allah
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam commanded
that when a person goes to visit someone
on his deathbed
that he encouraged the person to say la
illah
encourage those dying amongst you
to say
and if a person's last words of this
world
are lo
they will enter paradise as the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and this
is part of what allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala does
for a person while he is in sakhara till
mouth
in surat
ibrahim
allah subhanahu said youth
allah
[Silence]
foreign
a person should encourage that a
person's final words are
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam promised
that if a person's final words of this
world
are he is guaranteed
paradise the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam further
prohibited that we engage
in the traditions of the nations
of disbelief and that we
engage in the traditions of the people
of polytheism and the people of
un-islamic rituals
of these traditions is
whaling what is called wailing
right and in some cultures
this is considered a must because if a
person dies and nobody wails over his
death
this person is considered lowly in
society
and so for this reason they would even
hire
whalers right that would you can still
do it till today
and you can hire people to follow a
geneza
and wail and weep and cry and rip their
clothes apart and rip their hair out and
all these things
this is all of the ways of the people of
ignorance and the nations of disbelief
who do not believe in allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
they do not believe in allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
for the patient they do not believe in
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala's promise
b and they do not believe
in allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala's
commandment
was
seek aid through your hardships
through prayer and patience
indeed allah is always with those who
are patient they do not believe in these
concepts
and so they do things such as
raising their voices in wailing
they do things called a nadib which is
common amongst
our people in in
philistine and in the arab world you
will see this a lot
a person will passed away a person will
pass away
and they the bereaved
whether it be the mother or the wife or
the
usually women sometimes men they will
start to do what is called a nedib
a nedib is calling out to the deceased
why did you leave us how could you leave
us this
[Silence]
is
it doesn't mean that if you do not wail
it doesn't mean that you cannot be sad
sadness is a natural occurrence when
somebody passes away
when you see calamity when you see
hardship
sadness is almost inevitable
and this is not something that is
prohibited
as a matter of fact when the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's son passed away
ibrahim
he said in the narration in as
our eyes are flooded with tears
our hearts are filled with sadness
yet we will not say except that which
will please
the lord right and so a person may cry
and a person may be
sad and a person may be
bereaved a person may be even beside
himself
with grief but a person will always
experience these hard emotions
through the lens of islamic teaching and
discipline
that we hold ourselves to a higher
standard
we understand that death that
bereavement
that loss that hardship
that calamity that crisis
ultimately is from and by the will of
allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala and so the least
that we are
are as muslims is patient
we bear our tests with patience
forbearance hope
and we bear our tests
with faith this is a very important
point that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam taught his followers
also the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
mentioned that when a person is in the
presence of death
he should be in a state of
he should be in a state of calmness
and tranquility
he said it is of the sunnah
and the tradition of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
that when one is in the presence of
death
he is in a state of tranquility
and calmness there's this is not an
appropriate time
for joking this is not an appropriate
time for
salutations sometimes you go to the
graveyard
you go to a person's death
you go to a person's wake
even worse you go to bathe the body
and you find people cackling joking
laughing speaking loud
being rude speaking about things that
have nothing to do with the
current issue speaking about their own
lives
this is something which is abhorrent
right this is something which is
undignified death
is owed respect and the deceased
is owed respect and the family of the
deceased
are owed respect there are some times
when people
are around death enough their hearts
become
hard and they fail to realize the
seriousness of death
[Silence]
on
after a person passes away
there is a mentality and a statement
that we
say that mentality that
attitude that belief
and that statement that we put that
belief into words by
is along the lines of alhamdulillah
in
that a person say all praises to allah
even during this calamity all praise is
due to allah
subhanahu and that a person do what is
called al-istir
jaa what is
that a person say inna lillah
rajyan to allah we belong
and to he we are returning
also a person's heart should should be
filled
with patience and should be filled with
pleasure or i should say
acceptance is a more appropriate word
a person's heart should be filled with
acceptance
of what allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
has has
willed occur to this person
it's something that is difficult death
it is a major calamity even allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala referred to it as a
major calamity
but we are we are
accepting
and this is important for us to
understand
we don't always understand the
will of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
he wills for things to happen
they seem untimely
the things that he wills to happen seem
helter skelter and disorienting
some of the things that he wills seem to
be out of
place yet a person must always
trust in the timing of allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
that whatever happens at this particular
time
was the exact perfect time for it to
happen
because it is of the will of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
this doesn't mean that we will always
understand the will of allah
actually quite the contrary
most of the time we do not understand
the will of allah
subhanahu most of the time when we look
at
tragedy if you go walk through the
cancer ward at a hospital children's
cancer ward
or you go walking through war-torn
villages where children
are
killed mothers are bereaved
husbands go out and never return right
you see war-torn areas you see
famine you see
natural disasters that claim the lives
and property
of innumerable people we don't always
understand why these things happen
as a matter of fact most of the time we
don't know why they happen
and we may never know why they happen
but we don't need to because we know
who is the one behind these things
and that is allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and so it is enough for the believer to
say
this is of the decree and will of allah
and what he has willed he has done
i don't have to know why and even if i
were told why
most of the time we would not understand
because we are far we are short-sighted
ignorant human
so it's important for us in the face of
adversity
to trust in allah subhanahu
in times of hardship we exhibit patience
it doesn't mean that it is easy
and it doesn't mean that it's something
that we desire
or are happy with but it does
mean that it is something we
refer back to allah women
[Silence]
another of the aspects of the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam sunnah with regards to
the deceased the geneza
the body that is to be prepared
he says
is
[Silence]
that when a person pass away
he would hasten in preparing the body
for
burial what do we mean by hastening to
prepare the body for
burial hastening to prepare the body for
burial
means as soon as the person has passed
away
in our current time sometimes there's
paperwork
in a hospital if a person passes away in
a hospital setting
the body may need to be released but as
soon as these
formalities are out of the way
a person should hasten to
prepare the body what we mean by
preparation of the body
is to bathe the body to
clean the body
to put perfume and
tip on the body and also
to shroud the body most preferably
in white shrouds
the sunnah of the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam
is for the body to be shrouded in three
separate shrouds
and it is also preferable that one of
those shrouds
have pinstripes on them
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
was buried
and he was shrouded in three shrouds of
whites one of which contain
pinstripes this is preferable
it doesn't have to be let's say the only
shroud that we have
is brown or green or blue or or
black anything will suffice as a shroud
but white is the most preferable
color for the shroud of the deceased
[Silence]
after the body is properly prepared
it would be brought to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would then proceed to pray over the body
when we say pray we are speaking about
the prayer of geneza
the funeral prayer which is a very
specific
prayer and we will discuss its minutia
in a following in a following time
in sha allah now notice
from the moment the person fell ill
we're visiting the person we're with the
person
when the person is dying we're with the
person as he dies
we're encouraging him we're giving him
hope
we're reciting quran we're reminding him
of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's mercy
this is the most important thing you do
not want to
make a person on his deathbed feel
hopeless this is a great
crime with allah subhanahu
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]